[Music]
on this Saturday night Aid finally
trickles in to Gaza why humanitarian
groups say it's not nearly enough each
passing Day brings more and more people
in Gaza to be facing the risk of having
to starve as Israeli air strikes
intensify before the next stage our
interview with the former head of
intelligence of the mad and Canada's
multi-million dollar commitment for
Palestinians luxury condo lesson the
buyers don't know whether they're going
to be able to close the iconic Toronto
Mega Tower in major trouble plus space
origami this is a remarkable full
pattern the influence of an ancient
practice in outer
space global national with
[Music]
barasa celebrations echoed at the ra
Crossing between Egypt and Gaza as
trucks carrying Aid crossed for the
first time since Israel declared war on
Hamas two weeks ago
today good evening and thank you for
joining us after days of intense
negotiation desperately needed Aid is
finally entering Gaza including food
water and coffins but it's not nearly
enough according to Aid groups with only
23 trucks making it through today before
the conflict several hundred trucks
would arrive on a daily basis the UN
calls it just a drop in the ocean of
what's needed right now I went to the
Rafa border
crossing there I saw a paradox a
humanitarian catastrophe playing out in
real time on one hand I saw hundreds of
trucks theming with food and other
essential
supplies on the other hand we know that
just across the border there are 2
million people without water food food
fuel electricity and
Medicine children mothers the elderly
the sick full trucks on one side empty
stomachs on the
other and tonight the Israeli Defense
Forces are warning that the military is
now intensifying its air strikes on Gaza
before what it calls the next stage of
the war with attacks increasing supplies
running out and nowhere to go people in
Gaza are Beyond desperation ganing
begins our coverage from Jerusalem
tonight
Crystal far a world food program
representative who spoke with global
news says what Aid did manage to get
into Gaza today is not nearly enough
saying people need food and water every
day and that right now hundreds of
thousands are on the brink of
starvation for 2 weeks Israel has
pounded Gaza from the air we are asking
for you guys the Canadian government to
help us and hear us and take us out of
Gaza and help us be safe the sound of
explosions could be heard AS Global News
spoke with shatak underscoring the
desperate situation she and her family
are trying to survive this is my mother
this is my sister my brother and my
other sister we are all holders of the
Canadian passport me and my siblings
were all born in Canada and my mom has
the Canadian
citizenship K and her relatives are with
many other foreign Nationals at the
border crossing to Egypt hoping to
escape all Crossings were closed after
Israel declared war on Hamas which
governs the Enclave following the deadly
incursion by militants October 7th
there's no water no electricity not
anything the United Nations estimates
1.6 million people in Gaza are in
critical need of humanitarian Aid
Saturday morning saw the first
deliveries of food water and Medicine in
nearly 2 weeks the world food program
program says in order to avert a
catastrophe they need continuous access
each passing Day brings more and more
people in Gaza to be facing the risk of
having to starve and it's not just about
the food it's also about the water and
it's about the medicine and it's about
all these essential needs Palestinians
and Israeli civilians are
equal and both must be
protected they deserve to live in peace
and security with dignity and without
fear unlike the United States Canada was
invited to a peace Summit hosted by
Egypt the foreign affairs minister
announced more funding to support
humanitarian efforts for those trapped
in Gaza but there was no mention about
helping them get out as of right now we
are waiting for our death time we are
always scared bombs dropping here and
there whenever Global News is able to
connect with someone in Gaza they all
share similar fears and many ask the
same question who is going to help them
far crystal ganing in Jerusalem tonight
thank you Crystal now there are also
worries for the hundreds of hostages
taken by Hamas whose Fates remain
unknown now there was a glimmer of hope
on Friday after the armed group released
an American mother and daughter abducted
during their initial attack but many
other families are still desperate to
know more about their missing loved ones
mik
reports as Hamas was in the process of
handing over two American hostages to
the Red Cross their family was still
very much in the dark they had heard
rumors which were only confirmed when
they saw pictures on the news I've been
glue to the TV for two
weeks hoping for any good news finally
it came Judith and Natalie renan were
brought to an Israeli base for medical
clearance once that's done their family
is hoping they'll be able to return to
Chico Chicago for Natalie's 18th
birthday a celebration her brother says
will likely be muted there are still
hostages Israeli hostages American
hostages hostages from all over the
world um and and we care just as deeply
about those families as we do our own
because we know the pain of what's
happened around 200 hostages were taken
during the Hamas Raid 2 weeks ago that
peace is possible and you know that
Vivien silver a peace activist from
Winnipeg who would often bring sick
Palestinian children to Israeli
hospitals in Toronto raised Judy
Weinstein are the only Canadians
believed to be among the hostages their
families like so many others remain
desperate for
information the werts from Israel for
one only learned of 22-year-old om's
abduction when Hamas released this
chilling video since then nothing and
while the release of the first two
hostages has given the hope for their
son's release they're still as confused
as they are desperate the war is only
going to stop when all the kidnaps are
coming home former NBC Middle East
correspondent Martin Fletcher is related
to the two released Americans through
his wife he's reported extensively on
Hamas and worries the remaining hostages
will be used as human Shields but as
Hamas has a history of agreeing to
prisoner swaps one thing I'm pretty sure
of is in in this area of the world
nobody does something for nothing and
the hostages are hamas's last and best
bargaining chip Mike trle global
news as Mike just mentioned the families
and friends of these hostages are still
in limbo we're joined Now by Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa Mercedes you spoke
with a hostage negotiator with the FBI
uh with what could have gone on behind
the scenes what did you learn if far
Phil Andrew was was a negotiator with
the FBI for years he worked to get
hostages out of the custody of Terror
groups he is very familiar with this
kind of situation and he says the most
important thing right now for those
hostage negotiators is to try to make
the hostages seem like human beings like
people to their hostage takers so they
might be more willing to release them
but he says it's also Complicated by
what is a very unusual situation there's
normally a couple of hostages in this
case you're talking about over 200
different nationalities and potentially
different groups that have taken them
hostage all of which makes this more
difficult but he says that primary
strategy will remain the same of trying
to humanize them and convince them to
release those hostages not only on
humanitarian grounds uh for the hostages
sake but perhaps for their own sake as
this Israeli offensive uh grows closer
and closer and you know the hostages now
have been in Hamas custody for two weeks
is there do we have any idea of what
they're going
through yeah Phil Andrew says it's it's
a really critical time for these
hostages mental health because they've
been so severely traumatized and now
they have been in custody for an
extended period of time this is what he
told me well what the the hostages that
I have um debriefed have come out one
this is the you know the painful
traumatic experience um of of in which
they were taken is is probably not
something they been able to even process
and now that we're weeks into this this
is where you know the post-traumatic
stress starts to reveal itself so we're
at a very critical
time so the pressure really amping up
here far whether it's from the air
strikes or that imminent potential
Israeli incursion or the international
pressure uh to do something about the
humanitarian situation in Gaza no
question that those hostages just want
out no matter what the reason so much at
play okay thank you so much Mercedes
Stevenson in
Ottawa and you can watch mercedes's full
interview with Phil Andrew tomorrow on
the west block right here here on
global thousands of people around the
world including here in Canada held
rallies in solidarity with Palestinians
today calling for an end to the Gaza
conflict this is genocide this is
genocide hundreds gathered outside
Toronto's US Consulate calling for
freedom for Palestine displaying signs
with messages including solidarity has
no borders demonstrators also gathered
at Winnipeg's Memorial Park where they
briefly clashed with Israeli
[Applause]
supporters an estimated 100,000
demonstrators marched through the
Streets of London today expressing their
support for Palestinians while demanding
an immediate ceasefire in Gaza Pro
Palestinian rallies were also held in
Pakistan Germany and Spain amid growing
fears the conflict between Israel and
Hamas could expand across the region
global leaders saw sought to find a
diplomatic solution today at the Cairo
peace Summit conspicuously absent Israel
and any senior us officials as Reggie
Chini explains the US is Meed in its own
political turmoil which could spell
difficulties for President Joe Biden's
ability to help find a solution the
rumble of an explosion in Gaza and the
piercing whale of a siren across Israel
have become all too common in a conflict
seemingly impossible to end we see
terrible human grief and fear in Cairo a
hastily organized peace Summit aimed at
preventing a regional War brought
together heads of state and foreign
ministers but the path to peace is
fraught the Palestinian president railed
against forced
displacement we will not leave he said
others reiterated Israel's right to
defend itself while voicing concern for
civilians a child is dying every quarter
of an hour hour on inside Gaza this kind
not go on noticeably absent from this
forum senior us officials and Israel
lowering the expectation for a joint
statement let alone a resolution good
evening my fellow Americans on Thursday
President Biden spoke to an audience at
home stressing the risks Wars posed to
National Security and pleaded with
Congress to end the dysfunction time is
over the essence but this is a fine
needle to thread Biden has long been
losing Support over repeated Aid
packages for Ukraine and is now asking
for billions more for keev Israel and
Beyond Biden is basically asking the
taxpayers to uh accept the idea of100
billion Biden's foreign agenda is
running into Political headwinds at home
there's no h speaker to bring his
request to a vote and a government
shutdown is still possible meaning
public buyin may be limited unless there
is a direct impingement on their
security and prosperity most Americans
understandably have a lot of other
problems to deal with the US is now
facing a test to prove it can maintain
global stability without damaging its
own Reggie Chini Global News Washington
Israel's next steps coming up we speak
with a former Israeli intelligence head
on what else to expect as the crisis in
Gaza drags
on with the release of two hostages from
Gaza the situation continues to evolve
we're now joined by zahar paly former
head of the policy and political
military Bureau at Israel's Ministry of
defense and former director of
intelligence of the Mad thank you so
much Mr paly for joining us now this
time last week we were preparing for an
imminent ground offensive now we have
two hostages that have been released so
what does that tell us about Israel's
next
steps the next steps is first of all to
deal with this vicious uh I don't know
even how to call it horrible terror
attack that Hamas have done against the
states of Israel and of course against
civilians we need to put an end to this
madness of the Kamas in Gaza and all the
preparation is as you said for the grand
operation and we will do it
eventually so no timeline yet on when
that would
happen of course the operational issue
let's leave it aside right now in the
media because we don't want to let the
Kamas exactly when we are coming but uh
we are
there Mr py is it Beyond Israel's aim to
eliminate Hamas as you're mentioning is
the aim to reoccupy
Gaza let's start with the second
question we are not about to occupy Gaza
and to stay there we had the lesson from
Lebanon by the way we didn't have any
plan to take over Gaza we left Gaza in
2005 as you know um we don't have any uh
troops not IDF not settlements nothing
in Gaza and and uh we don't like to go
back there um that's why it seems to me
that the answer for that is no but no
doubt we have to remove these crazy guys
because and to remove this threat
because otherwise we'll face the same
challenge like every five minutes and
enough is enough Israel has said uh it
has taken steps to protect civilian
lives uh put up Flyers but we've seen
thousands of Civilian casualties how do
you explain
that first of all before thousands of
Civilian casualties we are right now are
speaking with the populations in the
last few days and it's a process um to
let them and to that let's say that the
most of the population the gazin
population we live the areas where we
are about to get in we are trying to be
very cgic in our methodology and to hit
mainly the bad guys over here but you
know Gaza is a very crowded place and
although we are very professional and we
are using a very accurate weapon system
same like uh you guys and the Americans
and as you know our force is quite good
in those issues um it's a war and we
will try to diminish as much as we can
the the civilian casualties but we will
be very determined in order to remove
this threat of the HS okay I will leave
it at that I really thank you for your
time Mr zoh poliy former director of
intelligence for the Mad thanks for the
conversation thank you so much really
appreciate all the best
[Music]
bye-bye Tower of trouble ahead the debt
and disarray of what was supposed to be
one of Canada's tallest residential
[Music]
buildings a luxury condo Tower in
Toronto is set to be one of Canada's
tallest housing projects yet the
multi-billion dollar project dubbed the
one is in disarray and as Mark arusell
reports nowhere near
completion the condo development known
as the one should have been scraping the
sky almost 330 m above Toronto's
downtown core by now instead it looks
more like the 0. five with concrete
walls and columns only poured up to the
40th floor of what's supposed to be an
85 story structure its developers $1.6
billion in debt to South Korean
investors construction will continue but
real estate lawyer Bob Aaron says people
who put down deposits on condos and
contractors on the job site are in for
some uncertainty the buyers don't know
whether they're going to be able to
close the trades who have supplied
materials and goods and
labor don't know whether they're going
to get paid industry experts see this as
a project specific incident not a sign
of impending doom for Canada's condo
Market however mortgage broker Ron
Butler suggests condos like the one born
in the good old days and carrying over
into today's inflated economy are bound
to feel the strain we've got roughly a
40% increase in construction costs over
the course of the last two years and we
all know that we have had triple
increase in financing cost luxury condos
are not developers say the bank of
Canada's interest rate hikes and the
uncertainty around them are scaring pre-
and postbuild buyers away we've seen a
major decline in the volume of units
sold in the last 18 months you know I
think this fall probably being the Apex
EV that uh but it's been a very very
slow 18 months with few options and a
growing number of people looking for
housing the need for new homes is
Extreme but the Canadian Center for
policy Alternatives says the rate hikes
meant to stabilize the economy have had
a dire impact on new builds of all types
single family homes are down by about a
third since rate hikes started semi
detached as well as apartment buildings
are down by about a quarter McDonald
says Federal housing initiatives like
the accelerator fund and sales tax
exemptions are not enough He suggests
governments need to get back into the
business of building and running
affordable housing Mar carcol Global
News
Toronto folding space next the ancient
ARS that could be the key to exploring
the
[Music]
cosmos as scientists work to study
planets outside our solar system they've
been looking for alternative solutions
to solve problems of weight and volume
Eric Sorenson looks at how an ancient
art could help us see more in space
it looks like something in art class but
centuries old origami is being
transformed into state-of-the-art space
technology this is a remarkable fold
pattern because uh even if I fold only
in One Direction the other direction
folds automatically Canadian aerospace
engineer manin Arya has found the
properties in traditional folding art
are ideal for a large lightweight
structure in space a star shade to
combat light pollution from trillions
and tril trillions of stars that obscure
what we can see deep in the universe a
star shade is a mechanism by which we
can block out the light of a star so we
can observe faint planets that are
orbiting that star scientists say that
star shade needs to be about the size of
a baseball diamond with petals that
allow an accompanying telescope to get a
clear look at
exoplanets and the shade blocks out
exactly the light of the star while
letting the light of the planet pass by
the side of the shade but to get
something that big into space that's
where origami comes in as Arya and his
team fold and refold and perfect a
daisy-shaped star shade origami teaches
us how to fold very large thin sheets
into very small spaces and that's
exactly what space engineers need NASA
has already succeeded with foldable
technology packed inside this spacecraft
was the James web telescope that was
unfolded perfectly in deep space and
ascended send in back remarkable new
images of the Universe imagine the
Distant Worlds in even more detail with
star shade Technology based on origami
Eric senson Global
News to learn more about the role of
origami in space watch Eric's full
report on the new reality Saturday at 7
on global and that's global national for
this Saturday night I'm far Naser and on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's yourk
Canada is the East Point of satna Island
British Columbia we'd love seeing your
canid so please keep emailing us your
photos to viewers at Global
national.com until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
[Music]
night